For Darkseid!
Lex Luthor fried the circuits bringing his creature to life.
There's not enough charge to wake the box
Welcome back, everyone it's Charlie.
This is good to be my new Justice league video.
There were a bunch of big headlines making
the rounds this morning you probably saw.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the Easter
eggs will do a new Amazon giveaway all you
do to enter is be subscriber and let me know
what you want them to do after the Justice
league Snyder cut if it's successful as it
seems like it's going to be for HBO Max what
you want their next big project to be so just
starting with number five if you didn't see
the news this morning.
The big thing is that Ray Fisher, the actor
who plays cyborg posted another very dramatic
statement about working on the Justice league
theatrical cut with Joss Whedon.
He also references Geoff Johns and Jon Berg
who the studio producers at that time working
on all the DC movies so this is the statement
that he made this is actually pretty big deal.
He says just means onset treatment of the
cast and crew of Justice league was gross,
abusive, unprofessional and completely unacceptable.
He was enabled in many ways by Jeff Johnson
Jon Berg accountability is greater than entertainment.
This is also in addition to the video that
he posted of himself from comic con 2017 a
couple of days ago saying that he like to
retract the statement that he was making in
the video from comic con 2017.
This was happening at the Justice league panel.
So this is the clip that he posted know what
they were just about finished with everything
for been brief.
If anything to me.
Joss is a great guardians epic a good person
to come in and in the cleanup and finish a
form as you can see was him just answering
a fans question during the Q&A portion of
the panel about what it was like working with
Joss Whedon on the movie after working with
Zack Snyder.
He gives a big thumbs up saying that it was
pretty great Zack Snyder picked a great person
to take over for him when it actually came
to hiring Joss whedon to come due though the
region's and take over the movie from Zack
Snyder.
I think that he was instrumental in reaching
out to Joss Whedon, but I think the studio
is also involved in that to but as you see
during the panel there when his answering
that fans question in front of thousands of
people and obviously making of his public
statements it's very political answer because
they were trying to hype up the movie.
This is a couple months before they release
the film studios have all kinds of PR stuff
built in the actors contracts saying that
they're not going to try and torpedo the movie
that they're promoting Walder on the press
to her.
That's why, even if the actor has a really
bad experience on a movie any movie doesn't
have to be a DC movie to be any movie anywhere
during the press tours usually you never hear
people saying stuff like this, the stuff that
cyborg is posting to his twitter account right
now.
Usually you only see major actors posting
stuff that big when they feel like they either
have nothing left to lose, or something really
terrible happened with no one harming their
relationship with the studio the directors
the producers that they're taking shots at
in their posts.
So number four what does that all mean what
is he saying Joss Whedon did on the set of
Justice league that was so bad what he's mostly
trying to call him out for being unprofessional
to the cast and crew to the point of being
abusive reading between the lines.
Remember what happened on that movie, so Joss
Whedon was brought in to do extensive re-shoots
and effectively Frankenstein create a whole
different type of movie than what Zack Snyder
was originally planning in a very, very short
amount of time.
So was already kind of an impossible situation
for everyone involved with that the studio
refusing to move the release date to give
them more time in my take on this just assuming
that actors tend to be a little bit overdramatic
is that Joss Whedon just ran everyone and
warp speed through filming all those new re-shoots
scenes and that's what led to the scenario
that Ray Fisher is calling abusive and unprofessional,
but not giving the actors and crew more time
to prepare for each of their scenes blowing
through takes as quickly as possible before
moving onto the next scene not giving them
quite as much feedback as he might give during
a traditional movie with a regular schedule
really good example.
I just posted a video of Hugh Jackman breaking
down all the Marvel Wolverine movies and during
that video.
He tells the story about filming the ending
scene of the Logan movie's final movie is
Wolverine as far as we know where Wolverine
is dying in the director James Mangold spent
a couple of hours just filming these 2 to
3 minutes of footage where he's in the process
of slowly dying because it was such a huge
moment for the character in the end of a 17
year journey of Hugh Jackman playing the character
in real life that it was someplace where I
was weak and he goes to the use of the use
was like a windmill wall little, so they wanted
to get the scene right so they just took way
way extra time than they normally would on
a traditional movie and Hugh Jackman just
said that James Mangold came in and said sit
here in the moment of this scene, and just
take it all and will just take as much time
as we need to get it right so clearly given
the schedule that they were on for the Justice
league re-shoots the opposite is what happened
for all those actors which is why think that
Ray Fisher cyborg is making all these really
really big posts number three.
The flipside of this and actor on Justice
league making a bunch of big statements like
this would be what Henry cavil has been doing
remember little while ago when all the Justice
league actors were posting about releasing
the Snyder cut it seem like everybody was
in on it like all the actors over this is
a big deal.
Maybe they really will release the Snyder
cut and then Henry cavil was surprisingly
the only one who was not posting about any
of it.
At that time there were a couple reasons for
that.
There's a couple reasons why he's never really
gone off in a big way about Snyder cut stuff
right after the movie came out he did talk
about coming back a Superman when he was still
promoting mission impossible he saw the mustache
he posted a couple videos to a social media
about doing future Superman movies, but the
reason why he was so quiet about it when the
other actors were posting about it one.
He was clearly still in negotiations with
the studio for new Superman contract for the
crossover movies that we just found out about
the supposed to appear in and still trying
to pitch them a new man of steel Superman
movie and had Henry cavil started posting
all kinds of incendiary statements it probably
would've hurt his chances of coming back before
the contracts had actually been signed and
the Ink has dried, but is also probably his
management team behind the scenes telling
him to just chill on all that stuff and be
little more diplomatic like is that actors
usually only start posting big stuff like
this when they feel like they aren't going
to be working with certain studios or producers
ever again or they don't feel like they have
anything left to lose the thing about this
though, is that the cyborg character is supposed
to show up during the flash flashpoint movie
so maybe cyborg has already re-signed a new
contract to come back for that we would talk
about Michael Keaton Batman appearing during
that for the past week or two just because
it's such huge news Michael Keaton coming
back his Batman for the flash movie and other
future DC movies.
This is so great, but also buried within that
were the flash producer saying that cyborg
would have some sort of role during the flash
movie, but number two.
As for that Justice league Snyder cut cyborg
clip is just a vision.
Cyborg has of the mother boxes dark side Green
Lantern in the dark side war, thousands of
years ago.
He singly interfaces with the kryptonian ship
and the mother box.
The whole idea is that he was created by one
of the mother boxes so it's part of them.
He's fundamentally linked to it and therefore
it knows everything that the mother box knows
her lease has access to all the information
that it holds the whole idea with his character
during the movie is that he still doesn't
understand everything in back when they were
still doing multiple Justice league movies
you would've seen his character of all to
learn to control his technology more than
the technology controlling him.
So this wasn't supposed to be him connecting
to dark side or speaking to him or anything
like that just having a vision of dark side
through the mother box like in the other Snyder
cut trailer that Zack Snyder posted a little
while ago wonder woman seeing dark side that
wasn't her speaking to dark side or anything
like that or her going back in time.
It was just her seeing a picture of dark side
is far as we know they were actually going
to literally meet dark side until the end
of the movie, but the ending of the Snyder
cut is going to be very, very different from
the ending of the theatrical cut, but number
one.
The two characters in the Snyder cut that
are probably getting the most new scenes are
Superman and cyborg they were barely in the
theatrical cut which also might be part of
the reason why the cyborg actor Ray Fisher
is making these post because he was kind of
taken out of the movie in the Joss Whedon
cut.
There were a ton of cyborg.
Deleted scenes from the Snyder cut that leaked
online after the movie came out you probably
seen at least a couple them.
There's some stuff that I added the beginning
of the videos there's a couple trailer scenes
of him re-creating some environments with
his new abilities and since the Snyder cut
is supposed to be over four hours long.
I'm assuming that all that every last speck
of new footage for all the characters is going
back in the also probably be a much bigger
trailer for it at the DC fandom comic con
panel Zack Snyder's going to be there in some
of the Center of everyone of the cast members
is participating so course I'll do videos
for all the footage that they drop so everyone
just post all your predictions in the comments
below and you can click here to rewatch that
Justice league Snyder cut trailer video and
click here to watch Hugh Jackman break down
all the Marvel Wolverine movies.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe see you guys tonight!